it's been an amazing journey you know
bodybuilding's given me so much it's a
road full of ups and downs I did
everything in life four weeks ago I was
in the bathroom crying honestly sobbing
with my girlfriend just like felt like
the law was getting to me with a lot of
pressure felt like things were just kind
of hard and tough and I wanted to just
quit to be honest I felt like I lost a
lot of faith in myself and it was
getting really hard to just push through
and I didn't quit obviously we're here
today but this morning before well after
prejudging I had that same cry in the
bathroom but this one was a cry of
gratitude and pride that I had pushed
through
and gone through that
and it's it's these moments it's this
journey and like like I felt this before
having the trophy around my neck it's
your journey it's the experience is
knowing that you pushed Past Times where
you wanted to quit
and you got done you pushed through it
so everyone out there whose dreams are
scaring you who dreams make you want to
quit just don't quit it's good your
dreams should be big they should be
scary just keep pushing through I have
this thing I say Champion mentality it's
not about winning it's not about a
trophy it's about having no quit it's
about giving everything you have so that
when you show up on game day before the
results are over you're proud of
yourself and you know the work you put
in
and that's all I can feel right now just
pride and gratitude to be here on this
stage I think the most the biggest
sacrifice I've made for professional
bodybuilding would be in my social life
especially coming from a very social
background in University I lived in the
house with seven guys and we kind of ran
a big party scene around our school we
hosted parties we all went to parties we
went out multiple times a week and then
all of a sudden I had to trim I didn't
have to I chose to transition into more
focusing and more on my career of
bodybuilding and I would they'd be going
out and asking me to come out and be
sitting in my room just kind of waiting
for them to leave and waiting to eat my
next meal got to get to bed early
because I had to wake up and do cardio
even now like people come back from out
of town people are wanting to hang out
first thing they ask you do you want to
go for dinner and you're in prep you're
like uh I can't go out you know you
can't eat you can't go out and it gets
to the point too where they're like oh
he's just gonna say no don't even bother
inviting him so you find certain certain
friends will stop even talking to you
because you're gonna you're that boring
guy so you miss out on a lot of social
life and probably my biggest sacrifice I
don't know if the success and failure
because a lot of people can be lucky and
successful but I think a huge thing some
people lack others not need more of it
you need to believe in yourself like
absolutely and fully know that you
believe in yourself or and I'm having an
understanding that if you are doing
everything at the best of your ability
that's in your control then you know you
will be successful from that and then
that kind of creates a release of
anxiety of the stuff that's out of your
control and you just focus on what is is
in your control I think all really
successful people have a mindset that
can detach from whatever the other
control whatever might happen or come
into your life and only focus on what
they can do and doing that at the best
of their ability at this stage in your
career how do you stay motivated this is
definitely something that has come in to
been a little bit more difficult in
recent years I kind of like feel like
I've accomplished a lot of what might
have wanted to accomplish and it's
almost like creating new goals in my
head that I need to chase after new
difficult tasks that I need to do and
it's nitpicking how I looked in years
past and understanding that I still
haven't looked exactly how I want to
look and I want to get on stage looking
like almost perfect at least once before
I retire so that kind of etches me to do
everything in a little bit better that I
wasn't doing properly last year like I
was talking about I want to Peak better
also just sitting down and like I said
picking new goals that it's going to be
I wanted to win the Olympia I want
Olympia twice I wanted to have the most
classic film Olympia titles I wanted to
when it was a perfect score I had these
like goals and I've accomplished all of
them now and now it's just like what do
you want next and I really would love to
be like remembered as to the end of time
as like one of the goats of classic Zeke
and I want to really like leave my
legacy on classic Physique in the ifbb
so my goal is to really accomplish that
and that's kind of keeping me motivated
right now so I'm trying to put my focus
on fine-tuning things chasing stuff I
tell myself in my head that people I'm
competing against are getting better and
better and that they're coming up after
me and that I need to push myself more
and more and just trying to remember why
I started all this because I just love
competing I love bodybuilding and I want
to keep improving being the best version
of myself winning isn't once what I
thought it was I found it to be much
more complex than our traditional
definitions of success a lot of people
fall to their knees in tears after a big
accomplishment partly due to Joy and
gratitude but a lot of what you see is
relief and even fear I don't say this to
be cynical but I've heard it from
various people and experienced it myself
it's a crucial moment in a person's
Journey where you need to ask yourself
what women means to you otherwise you
get stuck Mr wheel chasing a potentially
non-existent episode what I found is
that winning doesn't happen on show day
it happens in the early mornings painful
workouts long cardio sessions and hungry
nights happens in those moments of fear
we all have when faced with a difficult
goal and then more so and what you make
of that fear it happens in every second
of every day before you win if you can
take every opportunity you have to bring
yourself closer to your goal win every
one of those opportunities all while
becoming more resilient in the process
how can you lose that is an exciting
opportunity an exciting responsibility
to find out what you're truly capable of
a metal around your neck and a trophy in
your hands provides but a moment of
relief maybe a surge of excitement but
one that will quickly and surely fade
then you're back to square one and faced
with new decisions can I do it again
will I do it again there are new
challenges you face now you're so
focused on winning you didn't plan for
what comes next after all the hell you
just put yourself through are you ready
to do it again but with more intensity
if you're not improving you're falling
behind now you've shown the world what
you're capable of doing and they expect
nothing less another scary but exciting
opportunity another opportunity to grow
you may have busted your ass and gotten
lucky once but that was then and this is
now you can work 10 times smarter and
harder than you did before but you're
still promised nothing entering hell
blindly with no promise of what's on the
other end is one thing but getting to
paradise and then choosing to turn back
around into hell full well knowing what
to expect this time with a pipe dream of
a better Paradise on the other end
waiting for you that's Insanity the
history of the habit of calling
ambitious people crazy there's no
guarantee of what you'll find on the
other side of hell you may even be crazy
enough to learn that it was never hell
to begin with maybe just maybe you can
open your mind to the possibility that
paradise is found in how you choose to
look and act in this world Paradise like
our goals may not really be a
destination but an endless Horizon we
secretly don't want to reach a
never-ending reason to keep working and
growing with the intention not to
accomplish goals but to become someone
who can accomplish any goal winning
equally has no Finish Line to bet the
responsibility to ourselves to take
control of what little things you can in
this world regardless of circumstance to
train your mind to switch your
perspective and focus on being the
absolute best you can be in the areas
you do have control over having a
champion mentality isn't about the
trophies medals or success about having
no quit not letting anyone hear you
complain standing up for all you believe
in living in your truth and setting the
standard at which you operate at for
everything in your life it's about
willingly choosing to do every single
thing within your power to achieve your
end result at the end of it all you may
just find that the trophies and money
were never the prize you wanted but
rather the journey the mentality you
built along the way with everything
you've ever needed and I've always been
a huge believer that meant your
mentality your mental state your mental
toughness everything is a huge driver of
success and what separates like true
like long-lasting champions from people
who just win once or twice and it
developed a lot more over the years as I
started to really understand just how
important your mind is in competitive
Sports success career absolutely
anything and understanding that you are
Your Own Worst Enemy all the time you
are literally competing against yourself
all the time and that the champion
mentality isn't so much about being a
champion and winning trophies but it's
about having no quit like I said my
Olympia speech it's about giving your
all giving your best setting the
standard for yourself so that you are
putting in your best work to get your
own best results whether you win or lose
your
competing with a champion mentality to
be the best version of yourself it's
kind of what it's developed into and I
mean more every year I try and learn
more about my mental state and that's my
Champion mentality the battle internal
battle I have in my mind about my health
partly because of what I stuff I've gone
through in the past but also if you're a
bodybuilder and you're competing at a
high level and you have absolutely zero
concern for your health you're probably
lying and denying how you feel or you're
just stupid because obviously it's
you're putting a lot of stress on your
body you're doing a lot
so it definitely takes a toll on me and
sometimes I get these moments and I'm
like like is something happening am I
there's something wrong like why am I
doing this just to step on stage and
compete like is it worth it and I get in
these head battles like that and that's
when I know I need to be doing my health
checks blood work everything making sure
I'm healthy I'm working with a new
doctor now and making sure everything's
on point so I can like instead of
thinking I'm feeling good I know I'm
doing everything I can to feel good and
also just learning to not live in fear
because anything can happen at any time
in your life and if you choose to do
something then do it don't do it and
like stress about doing it or you might
as well not be doing it all because I
don't want to live my life like that
follow my journey all I want to show you
guys is to chase what you love and as
you're chasing it enjoy every step of
the journey along the way and just love
what you do because life is no other
purpose other than that so thank you
guys for following along I hope you
learned something from the stuff I share
and I love you guys